au canada plus de la moitié détruits
parce qu'encore leur vie dans des cages
d'un peu plus d'un mètre carré lorsqu
elles allaitent elles sont toujours
confinés dans le même espace une réalité
dont les principaux acteurs de
l'industrie porcine conventionnelles ont
refusé de nous parler
normand gagné lui a tourné le dos à
cette façon de faire en se consacrant à
l'élevage de porc biologique rouge en
effet de l'élevage conventionnel je
retournerai pas en mariage je vous le
dit littéralement elles se couchent elf
élèves à l'heure des repas une fois par
jour elle elle mange et elle fera couche
atteint 10 porté les prix malhonnête
parce qu'il pleut plus possible pour
être le moins cher possible
ces caches de gestation devait être
abandonné au canada en 2024 afin que les
truies soit élevé en groupe dans des
enclos en dehors de leur période de
gestation
mais certains membres de l'industrie ont
eu peur des coûts générés par la
construction de porcherie adapter à
cette nouvelle réalité
ils ont financé une étude pour voir si
c'était possible d'améliorer le
bien-être détruit en les sortant de leur
cage dix minutes par semaine
cette scientifique a participé à
l'élaboration du protocole de recherche
oui
nous avons regardé si c'était faisable
dans une porcherie moderne avec le
nombre d'animaux qui s'y trouve et c'est
un défi mais si ce n'est pas pratique
vous n'arriverez à rien
mais la sortie hebdomadaire n'a pas
donné les résultats escomptés
ça n'a pas diminué l'agitation détruit
nous améliorer leur confort parce qu'en
dehors des périodes d'exercice elle
était toujours confinés dans leurs
cadres
les cages de gestation devrait donc être
interdite en 2029 la nouvelle date
butoir pour les éleveurs de porcs
canadiens
en suède l'un des pays les plus avancés
en matière de bien-être animal les cages
de gestation sont interdites depuis 35
ans déjà explique cet agronome
les cages sont contre nature pour les
truies et ne peuvent pas exprimer leur
comportement naturel c'est très
restrictif
vous n'êtes jamais autorisé à mettre les
truies en cage sauf pour une brève
période de temps si elles sont
agressives envers les joints ou les
portionné mais c'est très inhabituel
a new show
janet et länder élève ses truies en
groupe havas terrasse au centre de la
suède
pour me thrill seconde tout signe j'aime
voir me criant liberté je pense que
c'est bon pour leur santé c'est
important pour moi
pendant la brève période où les truies
sont en cage avec leurs porcelets elles
doivent pouvoir bouger et se retourner
sans difficulté elle dispose de trois
fois plus d'espacé que les truies élevé
dans les autres pays de l'union
européenne au canada seuls les porcs
élevés en régie biologique ont des
conditions de vie similaires à ceux de
la suède comme chez du breton le
principal producteur de porc biologique
en amérique du nord ici quand elles sont
avec leurs porcelets les truies en trois
fois plus d espace qu en élevage
conventionnel on est dans un enclos 2000
bord on peut voir la truie qui est
libre de ses mouvements qui est capable
de se coucher deux fleuves et de se
retourner un peu comme elle veut mais à
peine un demi pour cent des producteurs
canadiens élève des porcs dans ces
conditions au standard de bien-être
animal plus élevé ici julie vaillancourt
radio canada montréal